[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday I have
good news and bad news first the good
news yes thanks to about 35,000
residents of the dominican republic we
managed to get our silver magic cord
that takes the ideas from inside the
camera and puts them inside the computer
from the big city which is like an hour
and a half away to the little city which
is here yes
and now the bad news Hank and I really
can't address this video to you because
you went off to the beach or whatever to
use the internet magic phone to talk to
the Catherine but anyway we had been
planning all week for an exciting
Brotherhood to moment of hilarity about
six weeks ago my cousin Braxton called
me and he said John I have good news and
I have great news and I said oh well
let's start with the good news and he
said my wife and I are going to have our
first child and I said wow that is
really really good news I can't imagine
what the great news is and then Braxton
said John the great news is this in the
Dominican Republic they have miniature
donkey polo miniature donkey polo now
before any new animal rights
nerdfighters get mad at me let me
quickly point out that miniature donkey
polo is not inhumane witness for example
Christopher Robin and/or huh-huh getting
ridden by Christopher Robin was the only
thing that ever made your happy add to
the long list of things I thought I
would never say but ended up saying on
Brotherhood 2.0 written by Christopher
Robin anyway Hank I've spent the last
six weeks looking forward to miniature
donkey polo and then I called this
morning because the miniature donkey
polo was scheduled for six o'clock and
they said that it had been canceled due
to heat I don't want to exploit the
donkeys but we're in the Dominican
Republic
how can you cancel something due to heat
it's always hot
here so unfortunately our reunion is
going to have to end without donkey polo
anyway Hank it's been a great week I've
loved hanging out with you it's been
every bit as fun as the growing pains
theme promised it would be I think we've
also learned a lot about microfinance
and poverty and what life is really like
in this country and I think we're
looking forward to making those videos
when we get back home to regular video
equipment land and really I think the
only way this trip could have been
better is if our grandparents had been
here and if Katherine had been here I
mean without them it does feel a little
bit like a family reunion instead of a
family reunion anybody anybody
mmm-hmm-hmm spelling jokes anyone no
okay
hey I'll see you tomorrow